brutale attacke in orten dunk ein 22
jähriger soll in rheinland-pfalz einem
anderen jungen mann mit einer machete
eine hand abgetrennt haben der 21
jährige erlitt bei der tat außerdem
verletzungen am kopf und schwebte
zeitweise sogar in lebensgefahr wie die
staatsanwaltschaft koblenz am montag
mitteilte ein augenzeuge berichtet wir
waren halt hier auf dem geburtstag haben
ein bisschen gefeiert und dann
irgendwann ist ein kumpel zu uns
gekommen hat gesagt hier der niklas also
der betroffene der hat halt die hand
abgeschlagen bekommen mit der machete
und dann sind wir direkt hingefahren
pumpe der benedikt heißt ja da waren wir
zu viert im auto
da hingefahren war ich gerade dann bei
dem jungen der betroffen war und dann
habe ich halt kurz in appen hoch
genommen habe als auch gesehen dass die
hand ab ist dann wollte ich noch mit dem
weiterreden auf einmal kam dann der sohn
von dem mann der mit der machete auf ihn
losgegangen ist
da hat er schon mit dem messer gedroht
verpisst euch wer seid ihr
und dann hat er halt die das messer
schon so gehalten und hat es schon
gedroht haben wir mit dem geredet haben
dem gesagt legte das messer jetzt sofort
auf dem boden
wir wollen wir mal mit dir reden was
hier passiert ist dann so nach 20 mal wo
wir gesagt haben legt das messer jetzt
mal auf dem boden hat er was abgelegt
und dann ist ein kumpel direkt auf den
draufgegangen hatte auf den boden
gedrückt und wir haben die polizei
angerufen und bild reporterin lisa das
ist mir jetzt live zugeschaltet lisa wir
haben es gerade gehört was der
augenzeuge sagt hatte was sagt er an die
staatsanwaltschaft zum tatablauf ja nach
neuestem ermittlungsstand der
staatsanwaltschaft wird sich das ganze
jetzt wirklich an wie ein horrorfilm und
zwar hat sich mittlerweile der
mutmaßliche täter auch eingelassen das
heißt er hat gestanden dass er nicklas
er die hand abgehackt hat allerdings
stellt er das ganze als eine
notwehrsituation da der mutmaßliche
täter sagt nämlich er hätte in seiner
gartenlaube holz gehackt und hätte dann
ein auto gesehen neben dem feldweg das
einen unfall gehabt hätte dann sei er
mit seiner machete dahin gegangen und
dann hätte plötzlich der autofahrer der
in dem auto gewesen wäre also in dem
unfallauto auf ihn geschossen
und weil dieser autofahrer also in die
klasse dann auf ihn geschossen hätte
hätte er ihn mit der machete die hand
abgetrennt so weil er das aus gesagt hat
muss die staatsanwaltschaft das
natürlich jetzt prüfen weil das wäre
eventuell eine notwehrsituation gewesen